when you look at the political landscape
economic landscape whatever it may be
what are the issues that you're most
concerned about I don't know if issues
keep you up at night but let's say they
did What Would those issues be so Robert
Reich yesterday I don't know if you know
who Robert Reich is professors socialist
you know left you know whatever you want
to call them right he tweets out
yesterday and he says there's no way a
CEO's average salary from 1978 till
today should increase
1470 percent a number like that he
tweets it out so the average person that
doesn't know numbers will look at that
and say what oh my God he's right why
should the average salary of a CO
increase
1478 percent these rich people are just
totally this this dead okay well the
average NBA player salary has increased
ten thousand percent the average salary
was 35 40 000 they're making 8.8 million
a year okay what is that a problem too
maybe we should look at that and by the
way majority of basketball players are
African-Americans so MBA who the founder
of the NBA was a white guy has helped
out the African-American Community
because majority of the best players in
the world in the NBA are
African-American now you're starting to
see some of these guys like Luca and
other guys that are coming in the game
but should we look at that and say NBA
players are pay too much because I think
they're paid too little if you ask me I
think LeBron needs to get paid 80
million a year 100 million years I think
some of these guys deserve to get paid a
lot more then I said what do you think
about the fact that College tuition from
1978 till today has increased fifteen
hundred percent give or take is that
okay why is college tuition increased
fifteen hundred percent since nineteen
seventy eight and then the other thing I
asked them at the end Robert Reich I
said so
while you're complaining about CEOs
making the kind of money that they're
making your keynote rate today you're
asking for a hundred thousand dollars an
hour that's more than 99.9 percent of
CEOs make in America per hour should we
be concerned about these numbers right
then you look at the commentary on what
people say oh somebody finally called
them out Patrick this is so disingenuous
how can you not understand what point
he's making Robert Reich a socialist so
they go and they debate right
if we cannot see both Robert reich's
point and my point and we can't see that
exchange where the person can make up
their minds and say I agree with Robert
I agree with Pat we have a problem okay
so my biggest fear is we're afraid of
debate today we're afraid of discourse
today we're afraid we're afraid of
people clashing ideas and God forbid it
gets us closer to the truth oh my God
this is a terrible idea the same Persian
girl that I had on so funny she's
anti-second Amendment she's anti all
this stuff that she's talking about
right I said let me ask you this
question uh Iran these women that are
protesting okay and they're going
through what they're going through in
New York Times said this is not about
women this is Iran's got bad economy and
you call them out New York Times because
your minor is in media criticism and
she's because New York Times part of her
Camp I said but these people are going
up against the government and the
government has guns and weapons but the
civilians don't have any weapons do you
think the way Iranians will be free
through a peaceful Revolution or a
violent revolution her answer oh it's
going to be a violent revolution
so to match the violence that the
government can impose on the Iranian
people what do you think we can do to
help the Iranian people well they need
guns they need weapons also your
pro-second Amendment got it so the whole
concept of Second Amendment is that if
the government ever wanted to become an
intrude the average person is going to
have some kind of a gun to protect
themselves against the government what a
great point you just made and you see
the look on her face right uh-oh I just
got so so the point again now the
audience can sit there and say oh that's
a good point Pat I you try to get it
right there and you cornered her that's
not cool it doesn't matter you get to
make up your mind so my fear all the way
at the top
is we're afraid of ideas that may offend
us because as long as we are okay
risking being wrong with an idea we'll
be okay because we're all going to be
wrong at some point but the moment we're
afraid and we just want everyone to hear
only one side of the story we're going
to be we're going to be facing a lot of
problems my fears are related as well I
fear a robot culture now where people
are completely passive until it's too
late where they don't worry about they
don't even think when you have that
second amendment argument with people
and you're debating they don't even
think that government could be the
problem it's like they forgot the whole
country's history they forgot completely
and they can't imagine because they're
so used to swallowing so much from
government all the time and you know
when we went through covet I just
couldn't believe how many business
owners in New York just swallowed the
lockdowns and I was just thinking if you
had band together and just said we're
not shutting down not one business not
two businesses but a whole bunch of
businesses just said we're just gonna
say what do you think that we're gonna
do you know if people walked into their
company and said hey we have letters
tomorrow our doctors and we're not going
to get this experimental vaccine right
now we don't feel comfortable we weren't
going to let the whole company go so
it's just this passivity so you have the
passivity of the population
juxtaposed with this increasingly
centralized power structure that's very
concerning you know I look at someone
like you you've made a lot of money and
I say does it keep you up at night that
there could be a digital currency does
he keep you up at night having money and
I don't know where your money is but if
your money's in these traditional
banking systems because when you did
that interview with Tate the thing that
stuck out to me is him saying they
didn't just comfort me on YouTube and on
social they came for me on Airbnb and
Uber and this all gets very concerning
when there's a centralized power
structure that suddenly decides your
misinformation or your misinformation
and everything shuts down and you have a
largely passive population that's very
comfortable with swallowing Authority
even if it's tyrannical so does that
stuff keep you up at night temporarily
yes long term no because temporarily
that will scare you but long term
someone's going to find a solution
that's will willing to take your money
you what what you're always going to
need is the following if I work for a
company let's just say I work for a
company
and the reason why I have no fear
working for anybody partnering up with
anybody is the following reason I'm
going to bring value I'm going to
improve I'm going to lead I'm gonna
bring my best to the company I'll
outwork out improve out strategize
Outlast I'm gonna do this okay
and let's just say all of a sudden you
know the company starts saying wow you
know Patrick's being to this and
Patrick's been to that and we got to be
careful with Patrick this is no problem
there's a place for me everywhere in the
market there's a high demand for leaders
who lead respect and prove love who
outwork out improve out strategize
Outlast period someone's gonna want
someone like me in their company in
their state in their city in their
country so if you do that part right
there's always going to be a place like
JPMorgan Chase comes out and says hey
Kanye we don't want your money anymore
Yeah by November 10th or whatever the
date it is you got to take your money
out and go elsewhere okay no problem say
he's got a billion dollars in a bank say
he's got 300 million dollars in his
Chase account whatever the number is
because most of the time billionaires
people think they have six billion
sitting in an account a person worth 6
billion typically only has 10 percent in
cash everything else is all over the
place even less than 10 in cash so his
600 million dollars let's just say you
don't think there's another place that
wants a 600 million dollars that they
can take from him and lend to another
person and have an Arbitrage and make
the difference there's so many places he
can put his money to he's laughing Banks
and swiss or Banks and Singapore are
saying Kanye how you doing Mr Kanye we
love your music let me tell you the best
of the best we will be more than happy
to take your 600 million dollars and
matter of fact we'll give you four
percent interest if you bring it to us
at the bank of Singapore or Bank of
whatever capitalism works you can try to
bully a capitalists capitalists are
always in demand someone's always going
to want to because it's hard if being a
capitalist was easy there'd be 10 Kanye
West there's not there's only one if
capitalism would be so easy there would
be ten Elon musks there's only one
there's only it's not that easy to go
out there and build a business pay the
price potentially lose your you know
relationship late nights people are
partying you're not you have to study
you're going through a lawsuit you're
going through an issue with a competitor
your lost people here customers
someone's unhappy it's not easy it is a
very very hard thing to do but no matter
what people say about Elon Musk how much
you think like if Elon right now is
saying he's gonna he has to sell 11
billion hours of shares on Twitter so I
posed a question earlier I said so Elon
has to say 11 billion dollars of Tesla
to put into Twitter would you rather
have 11 billion dollars in Tesla or 11
billion dollars on Twitter you know what
people said as long as elon's at the
time right I don't care where the money
is at because I know he's running it
right right so yeah short-term it'll be
a headache if somebody cancels you but
the the Market's always in demand for
capitalists always if you want to watch
the full episode you're going to click
right here and if you want to ask me a
question one on one you want to do a
one-on-one FaceTime with a group of your
friends whatever you want you need to
download minute right now click right
here and let's get talking
thank you